the smell of smoke and poor visibility
with us for a third straight day things
could change soon though precautions
though still need to be taken not just
for people but for pets let's go to
Global shilima Maharaja shilima
good evening Alan for the last several
days the city has been invalid by that
thick and at times extremely pungent
smoke some of the people we've been
talking to told us about symptoms like
dry itchy eyes or itchy throats as well
and so all of that irritation that comes
this little surprise given the air
quality that we're dealing with right
now that's what has Health Care
officials urging people to limit their
time in the outdoors and to pay extra
close attention to those advisories
for 25 years living in Taron that's the
first time the first time Oleg plaqueoff
has seen this level of haze in the city
last two days very
be very bad you know like a smell is
like different right now there are 56
wildfires actively burning in Ontario
Toronto has been blanketed by forest
fire smoke bringing with it considerable
air pollution we have the air quality
Health index which is a value typically
between one and ten usually we sit
between one and three you know it was
above 10 for periods of time over the
last few days the University of
Toronto's Matthew Adams says what we're
dealing with is fine particulate matter
and the problem with them is they don't
get caught in our nose or in our throat
and get expelled like larger particles
would they can travel deep into the
lungs into the bloodstream and really
travel to every organ of the body the
immediate effects could include
shortness of breath dry eyes and
irritation of the nose and throat
Toronto public health is advising people
to reduce the intensity of any outdoor
activities or reschedule them all
together we have a zoo International
Management System where we have all our
animals on record so so the first thing
was to look at which animals had a
history of any kind of respiratory
illness or disease at
the tragic or very young animals one of
our gorillas has had pneumonia a number
of times he's a younger animal but he's
predisposed to pneumonia so that's an
animal that has a respiratory illness
for pets it's also important to minimize
exposure the Toronto Humane Society
recommends shortening walks outside
elderly animals animals with underlying
health issues and brachycephalics dogs
and cats with shorter smooshy faces
which are already at increased risk for
respiratory disease
now the Canadian Lung Association on its
forest fire webpage does issue a few
tips as well they suggest that people
limit their time Outdoors keep those
doors and windows at your homes shut and
as well if you are considering going
outside to exercise maybe reconsider
that for the sake of your health